let's not call here's what here's the
deal okay
if you could help me get shin lim on
this podcast i think that would be good
um
we'll ask him now yeah i can ask him all
right [ __ ] it all right let's do it get
him but if he doesn't pick up we're
stopping
and we're gonna go to unhelpful advice
when did we do my podcast how long ago
uh like like three weeks ago a month ago
month ago yeah yeah yeah okay
because i'm going to tell shin we're
still doing it
i'll tell them it's the same podcast i'm
still here with bobby lee we've been
waiting for you to call back
hmm
here he is
hi shin howie mandel again
are you busy
he's busy he's busy
he's walking you're walking to the
mirage
if it's a mirage you'll never get there
see what i did there
i'm still with
i'm still with uh bobby lee you remember
last time i called
you know what he told me he's i'm doing
his podcast right now his girlfriend
just told me that he was very depressed
that you didn't know who he was do you
know who bobby lee is
yeah
yeah he knows your name yeah yeah he
didn't he's too young to watch yeah yeah
yeah i get it the other stuff but he's a
he's your biggest fan i love bit magical
asians tell him that he says he loves
magical asians is that okay for me to
say that's what he no but i said that
because he said it yeah yeah i don't get
offended
yeah yeah here that's it he just you
would tell him so shin i like magical
asians
oh well thank you thank you very much
so [ __ ] i know you've heard of my name
but the thing is if you're ever in los
angeles please do my podcast because i
have a huge audience and they would love
you
okay okay
thank you so much for letting me know
that okay thank you when i go to ellie
okay thank you no but do is do his
podcast i'm telling you it's huge you
look it up the tiger belly yeah yeah
what what are you saying oh yeah yeah
his best friend he knows this his best
friend works for us too sometimes your
best friend works jason jason
you know jason
yeah jason look how familiar he is with
his best friend so how do you feel
better okay
anyway
i love you buddy hi jen
oh
all right he's crossing the street you
just killed chinless
now he just [ __ ] killed him i'm gonna
tell you right now he was walking to the
mirage now you heard the screech and now
everyone in the room do you believe now
do you believe my what i'm saying i do
thank you so much
what is it
he's heard of my name that's like saying
hey do you know chad norris yeah i've
heard of him
the name i don't know what he does but
i've heard of those i don't know but i'm
just making it up right so you're saying
that you are the chad norris of
shin lim universe
no no there's chad norris there he is
he's an author an author right oh signs
and wonder yeah yeah he he wrote vice
versa right which is the same book as
the first one except backwards
you know robert e lee the general
one of my favorite generals robert e lee
robert e lee you're right yeah so he you
know he's heard of robert lee right so
and he said it's like
wait a minute that's not you it doesn't
matter he's heard of the name
right but he doesn't know who i am
nobody is mixing you up with robert e
lee
nobody
i know he's young but they don't people
you're from isn't that from the civil
war yeah yeah yeah i'm not american and
i know that yeah
but um he doesn't know who i am and it's
like and that's what i'm saying oh no
look at the comforting thing that's you
understand what i'm saying you heard him
oh he's like what oh why are you why are
you feeding into his insecurity
well it's just because the obsession
runs so deep and i don't think it's an
insecurity as much as it's just a a
sadness
yeah and an acceptance it's an
acceptance with that sadness so i'm okay
with that
you know what
we're all speaking our truth
yeah yeah
it's it's it's like this what the [ __ ]
one time i always hear people say that i
don't know what that means
this is my truth i i'm a big fan of this
band called the pixies i know the pixels
okay so when i first met joy santiago
the guitarist right see and i didn't
know the guitar's name is joey santiago
but i know the pixies yeah so when i
first met joey though i was like ah
it'll be really heartbreaking
for some reason if he just didn't know
who i was i don't want him to treat me
just like this fan right which would
have been okay anyway but it's like when
i go what's up and bobby is like i'm a
huge fan i'm a huge fan you know i mean
we were able to be friends we exchanged
numbers we're good friends now you know
we talk to each other that's what i
wanted out of shin
but it's like you know it's not like
that and that's fine you wanted an asian
brotherhood i wanted a magical asian
brotherhood
instead yeah your neurosis got him hit
by a car and killed
he didn't die
well i don't know yeah
i want to maybe it was can i i have some
american got talent question why can't
we solve other people's problems yeah
let's do that yeah all right i've
changed
the voice do the voice
helpful advice with bobby kalila and
howie mandel
i'm a 22 year old male listener
currently studying you realize that the
same person
the announcer of this segment is the
same person reading you changed your
voice
oh
no i just thought that was amazing it
makes it seem like it's more i used to
when i had the carpet business when i
started the carpet business no i used to
answer the phone warehouse oh [ __ ]
is that my wife again
who's acting
right who is it
how do you know okay hold on speaker
hold on hello
hello hey is this bobby yeah
hey uh my jace jason texted me your
number okay who is this
oh this is chin
okay okay
[ __ ] okay this is great
i was just complaining about how i mean
but now that i have your number
right i'm so excited right i just want
to let you know okay that i'm sorry for
being weird but i just i i i honestly i
watch your videos ten thousand times a
day right i watch your moves i'm a huge
fan i think you're just magical and i
think you're asian and everything yeah
yeah yeah and i really love you so
you know one day you know me it's just a
dream of mine to have you on my podcast
if you're ever in l.a okay
all right you know what i might even
just make it up early just for that wow
okay
thank you so much man all right thank
you for calling i have your is this your
number this is my cell yeah okay good
i'm gonna save it this is magical thank
you oh no of course thank you thank you
bye shannon
okay
wow
how we making magic now so now i want to
get in touch with that jew
[Laughter]
i want a magical magical jew all right
so now that okay i'm sweating now oh wow
you got yours who cares we're not gonna
do that [ __ ] that now yeah
no no
i have to admit i think i have a gay
fantasy because my body got physically
sexual we all saw it yeah and i think i
will tell you this if you [ __ ] him don't
mess his hair
i know i would never touch his hair but
i think i have problems so i'm just
going to sweat that okay everything's
fine wow that so now i want to know how
that isn't that a drop to mike end of
the show
yeah thank you
let's just end it i think that was
perfect all right so um how we thank you
for being one of our best of my favorite
people in the whole world and thank you
for taking your time to contaminate
coming here and i just i get flustered
but